[Music]
now you understand there's going to be
some scarring
but i've already scheduled a surgeon
give me a mirror harvey maybe you should
wait until i said give me a mirror
[Music]
now
[Music]
ah
what happened
[Music]
harvey
goodbye grace
[Music]
justice is served hot batman
you're going to melt just like a grilled
cheese
sandwich
a late night rendezvous to what do i owe
the honor
harvey dent oh the poor district
attorney
i hear he's not expected to live oh
it's so sad
[Laughter]
why isley oh please call me poison ivy
you see harvey had to pay for his crime
what crime why murder of course
plowing up a field of beautiful
wildflowers for that silly penitentiary
of his
this little rose would be extinct today
if i hadn't saved my precious
from those horrible bulldozers
the blood of those flowers are on his
hands
so his fate was sealed
[Music]
with a kiss and now
so is yours
oh what's wrong afraid i have
cooties
where's muckridge in the center of the
maze along with the minotaur robot
i programmed it to destroy him at
exactly 4
30 a.m which gives you less than
10 minutes to run the maze and find him
but first
throw down your utility belts it'll be
more
interesting that way don't you think
now you may enter
[Music]
it's been smashing oswald
it needn't end this way i i truly was
growing fond of you
we we might have been friends we still
might
yes we all might sorry
tis better to have loved and lost and
made a small profit
than never to have loved at all
fashionably late i see
on to act two
[Music]
and who says opera has to be boring
i will finish this
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
the cold eyes of vengeance are upon you
boyle who who
are you come now surely you remember
your old
colleague victor freeze
who are you i am fear incarnate
i am the terror of gotham i am the
scarecrow
give it up there's no way out except
through you
[Music]
[Music]
fight all you want batman but you must
succumb
to the fear
[Music]
what hidden terror keeps the batman
awake at night
come on new queens my work is done
i'm having a bad day i'm sick of people
trying to
joke me run me over and blow me up
i didn't even get to keep my new dress
and i
actually paid for it
[Music]
i tried to be good i really did but if
that's not good enough
fine let's get back to basics
[Music]
talk about grasping at straws oh well
at least i'm going out on a joke
you